hello screen junkies welcome to a live
on youtube monday edition of screen
junkies universe and there's only one
thing to talk about on this Monday and
that is Batman V Superman dawn of
Justice
we did a non-spoiler review last week if
the movie is out the opening box office
has come in and now it is time to delve
deep into the world of Batman V Superman
and I have two of my favorite people to
do it with us here first of all he is
the editor in chief at heroic Hollywood
thank you for coming back on Berto
Gonzales thank you for having me then
and of course as always Andi signor who
Batman vs Superman us do it so guys we
really want to talk to you guys we want
to know we've been hearing your thoughts
on Twitter we've been hearing your
thoughts on YouTube and just about
anywhere that people have thoughts we've
been hearing thoughts all weekend about
Batman V Superman so today if you want
to join the conversation you can you can
tweet us at the hashtag SJ BVS you can
ask us questions there you can also join
the conversation live via Skype call
screen junkies live on skype our
operators are standing by to take your
call because really we want to hear from
you guys because this is a movie as
anticipated that has generated so much
fan discussion it has been going on
since the preview started last Monday it
continued deep into the weekend so first
of all guys I'm excited also to talk
spoilers which we should say exactly
this is Warren this is a spoiler review
this is a spoiler chat this is a spoiler
discussion so if you have not seen
Batman V Superman this is your last
warning we will be delving deep into
spoiler land so you have been warned
just first off guys first impressions I
know Andy you're a little more negative
on it I know Umberto you're a little
more positive on well okay let me say
this because I know we're Marvel junkies
right Dan
look I was real I like parks this movie
a lot it was really excited for this
movie I just still where I'm frustrated
I'm not trying to get DC fans rally
against me or us like I'm glad people
are enjoying this movie I am frustrated
because I think more people would have
enjoyed this movie including DC fans if
they had just taken their time a little
bit more and not rush to it in a case in
point let's go full on spoiler I hated
that they killed Superman I feel like
they rushed incredibly into that as well
there was just so much they had to keep
going and going going I just felt like
the the impact the amazingness of these
two coming together was just such a
frustrating rush to me where I yes I
enjoy the kidding me loved seeing them
fight I love the Batman fight I loved
actually Ben Affleck lot but man I just
wish they could have just slowed down a
little bit or and just refocused their
energy on just the Batman's to Brent and
also really sorry to keep going but I
really was disappoint I want see more
Superman I just feel like we've already
killed him off I still don't really feel
like I've got a grasp of him
darker good it doesn't matter to me like
I stink get it sorry I'm Berta what do
you think um I saw with the the fan
audience on Monday and they lost their
minds then I went through the critics
screen and of course it was me I was
there yeah we did the old media and then
I will start open that with a crowd and
they lost their minds to grant it was
probably their target audience the
fanboy audience and it was front-loaded
but if we're grating they got you got
three characters okay so the Batman
works
yes that's unanimous even the most
savage reviews yeah okay
Wonder Woman although she's window
dressing she's affected window dressing
crowds love her
yeah Superman okay he mopes around a lot
in the movie okay
so based on that Matt we get a 60 out of
100 that's a passing grade it is you
know how could you fail when those I
would understand the venom being spit at
the movie but Batman works it's just the
now we're talking spoilers the safe mark
the sequence that starts the third act
is the best Batman sequence ever
committed to film you see choreography
we see his brutality we see him move in
the costume it was it was I fell in love
with that scene I felt like that's
finally the Batman I've been wanting to
see I took a bath at the Martha scene
was not as good this is
before it yeah you mean a parlor wait we
would say mom's names then okay we're
friends every step is a step mother's
meal it's been going around this week
and it's pretty good but I agree with
you as a huge Batman fan he was the
first superhero that I loved and is
still my favorite that sequence in the
warehouse was Batman yes it was Batman
yeah okay you don't even like the movie
but Batman works yeah and I went to the
reviewers that don't like the movie and
they all love Batman yeah how could you
go wrong with battle look at least we
got that that's that saves the movie
well and I and I think that a lot of
reaction even amongst us and amongst a
lot of the the even the people that like
the movie is not so much I think a lot
of people's issues with Man of Steel
where the overall direction of the movie
the tone that maybe they didn't agree
with I think people that like this movie
and don't like this movie have the same
sorts of criticisms it's the lack of
focus the fact that it does kind of do a
lot of setup it touch the jam a watt
into one movie then it was maybe a
little schizophrenic and all over the
place and I and I feel like I've gotten
a lot of the reaction and I've seen a
lot of reaction from people that say
like you know what I like this movie a
lot but I see where the critics are
coming I agree I'm on the same page I
like I like the movie quite a lot but I
understand why it's divisive yeah
absolutely yeah I mean I just
frustrating because I've got a record I
didn't like Man of Steel but I really
did leave this movie liking Man of Steel
but better because again I felt like
they rushed everything I'm saying myself
but it's like even let's just talk
spoilers now the Justice League can we
go can we talk about there let's talk
like Justice League
hey there's a lot of pressure on us now
Dan to make a nice trailer for this
there this will definitely be in it we
thought I'd just resent but just from
the fact that I loved they the icons
like some with some graphic designer
like Scorpia made some they really look
great but like when you're hiding your
Aquaman your cyborg shots I'm gonna make
a cool logo for but beyond that you can
still eNOS I did not like them being
revealed in that way like I I'm excited
for those movies but they made me a
little less excited because I don't want
to meet cyborg and Aquaman through a
viral video on a laptop like I tend to
agree flash I was into I like the show
cameo and I want to talk about that
because I think we know what he said but
man the Aquaman one and he's that weird
come on
his look like you was holding his breath
why was he staring the camera so long
like give me like a badass get the hell
out of here like who was it just many
books he broke the sound barrier in
water you got even though you can't do
that you got it like that yeah well for
me even even more so it was kind of an
example of again they didn't seem to
know quite because even its placement in
the movie I found curious just as an
editor because it came in the middle of
the building action which is that you've
set up this is Batman V Superman in use
and this is literally the stakes have
been set Lex Luthor and bat has set
Superman on the course to go get Batman
Superman goes to fight Batman and they
literally right before the main fight
cut away to this for my sequence of
Wonder Woman checking your email and
seeing these videos and and again beyond
beyond the fact that it was a strange
for me a little bit of a strange way to
introduce the Justice League members in
that way its placement in the movie
itself was a little odd and and that was
my that's my main thing with the movie
was I'm mixed to negative on on it only
be mainly because for the first hour and
a half of the movie there was no thread
really it was just here's the scene
here's the scene here's a dream sequence
here's a nightmare here's a nightmare
sequence here's another gem stick I
don't know what this camera say like
having Costner sequence was was that a
dream why was Superman where he was he'd
never judge a movie it was very was
almost like a fever dream I do want to
see Mad Max Batman that looked awesome
that looked great the nightmare sequence
a dark side and I'll amiga symbol that
look great yeah so let's take them one
by one because I think we should talk
about that I want it we should open up
the colors I think soon because we're
going to talk a little bit a lot of
feedback online a lot of people sigh
this movie's dividing people I think in
a way that people are frustrated people
like it it is it can we just agree like
you're lighting like the movie we're not
trying to argue Asian like movie they
were just having a discussion here and I
want you guys to call in to talk to us
to explain either your what you loved
what you didn't love what we can talk
about um do we have a caller yes we do
jack is on the line hello jack you're
live on a screen junkies what's up man
hey Jack how are you doing good now are
you man what's your thought yeah I'll
get to this real quick I just have to
watch some YouTube videos
uh then I'll get back to your call hang
hang on one second so Jack I say that
you you apparently also shared some
issues with the structure of the film I
have two pages of new oh wow time enough
for that gimme one what's your most
glaring eye video though okay now I'm
not a DC guy I am legitimately a Marvel
guy it's just I just read those kind of
comics when I was growing up it's
nothing against DC I love Batman but uh
I didn't know about the whole Martha
thing so so like we're in the middle of
a fight and like we're kidding each
other's ass and then I'm like really
like his mom's name it is the same oh
wait they're gonna remind us they're
gonna show us all the reminder was
really frustrating oh and I was like oh
this is why we had to watch his origin
story for like the fifth time in a movie
because we needed to know his mom's name
was Martha snacks like does she did
shoot the pearls and then sewer very
well though I will give him that oh well
I how many times have we send the pearls
on the sidewalk I mean was it a new
cinematic flair to it try to be positive
how many times are we gonna see pearls
in the sewer though it's yeah I mean
that's part of how many times is he
gonna fall in a hole and see bats and
that's why he's in the Batman you know
it was kind of encouraging that Batman
was older we didn't need it I agree we
didn't need it I think you needed it
though because they said the Martha
thing which thank you for bringing up
Jackie well is the connection me but
yeah let's talk about that the Martha
Martha moment has been a very divisive
moment for a lot of people love that
moment a lot of people don't
particularly like that moment the
original line before the movie was know
Martha's will die tonight I guess in the
rewrites or an editing I guess they'd be
they said that to what it is now
what did Murray I forgot what he said no
more he does not know Martha's not gonna
die tonight or something right they fix
that they fix the line and they had a
lot of cheese to it I mean some people
honestly cried I mean the younger guys I
mean my admin is like got to me they're
they're younger they're like oh my god
that was a great line everybody was
crying in the theaters like come on
really yeah well it was just rushed they
said to me it was like yeah you had this
amazing showdown and I know you I want
you to talk about toukas digs we were
talking about it but the Lex Luthor sort
of cut at the knees before he goes it's
whistling but you can't bloom but we're
gonna fight wait our moms have the same
name okay
we're good it's just so easy but but I I
but that's the you bring up a good point
because it seems that the deeper that
you are into the DC mythology and and DC
has a very dense mythology with a
multiverse and everything it seemed to
me just reaction online that the more
that you knew about that and the deeper
that you were into that the more you
seemed to enjoy this film for example
the flash dream sequence I'm not exactly
sure what it was cforce which again I
I'm a fan of the flash as a character
but I I don't know that that I do not
know that much about the mythology and
it seemed like people that didn't know
about that were like what was that but
people that did were really excited by
it no I was I was confused at first and
then I had to ask my guys what was that
and then a second I'll be honest yeah
and in the second time is it oh okay so
that's what the speedforce suit looks
like lucky when he was saying it was
very hard to hear but he is deciphering
what we thought he said is don't try
don't trust him it was you were right
about we're right about Han well you
read to him about him we don't know
those things the key um and am I too
early am I too early or too soon too
soon did I come too soon is what they
were speculating is he did he come too
soon when he wasn't supposed to be there
right about him all along now right and
I would say I like I like that and it
feels like sort of back the future too
and I'm in and I am assuming they're
gonna use that obviously later right
we'll see him go back and whether that
was right or wrong so I like that they
went there I didn't like that he didn't
just give us the audio for it hahaha
it's difficult to get on the scene like
that like let's just here we saying so
we can then pick up and to get to the
uninitiated it's it's not clear whether
that was a dream or not it's not clear
who that was really or why they're there
and and really if you were to lift that
entire sequence out of the film it
wouldn't have that much impact on the
overall movement which which again I
think that what happened it was it was
cool to have but I think that a lot of
the divide is is that it was just a very
unfocused film to a lot of people
including myself okay uh can we have
another caller
Keith Keith you are on the line hello hi
hi how are you so it's I'm actually
quite good I saw the movie twice and I
think it's a six out of nine oh boy the
office yep it's a passing grade that I
was come on I want some people loved
this movie to call in get us people love
this movie too : passing grid I know
you're all yelling at me in the comments
get on the show but Keith go ahead why
didn't you why only a six out of nine
well there were some absolutely great
things like Batman I loved him I loved
the action of the fighting between
Batman and Superman although being a bit
short but it has some really big issues
in terms of in terms of story and
editing so yeah that's basically it
I'm gonna I was wondering what do you
guys think about the r-rated director's
cut that is about three hours long great
question yeah I think your piece for
calling in yeah and over the weekend
they push that release we already have a
date for that I think it's July buntings
there's my birthday July 16 July 16th so
we already know when that's coming out
and a lot of people have asked that
question do you think the 30 minutes
extra time will improve this movie I
would hope so because one thing that I
know it's there's a scene where Superman
goes to investigate Batman and Gotham
City supposedly so that's probably where
he figures out that it's Bruce Wayne and
I think the hard arse because Batman
drops a couple of f-bombs oh wow yeah
that Batman well that would mean that'll
really make the fans happier the people
that weren't having the Batman killed
now is job travel just a couple of bombs
yeah uh yeah I mean I to me the biggest
story that was lacking with Superman
like I'm still hung up on now I can sort
of accept and forgive and move on from
Man of Steel my issues with it because
all right I get it
yeah but I feel like I still
this idea of does the world need a
Superman it just was so glossed over and
then they even the Senate bombing like
it happens Lindsay see they don't really
use it like did they are that is the
public upset with him makes a rush
through it because they know there are
they aren't they're just trying to get
to Lex and his plan for doomsday which
to me I didn't need it in this movie
like I wanted Batman and Superman and
then they could have stopped Lex but
then we could have teased that he was
growing doomsday for the next movie like
there was a million ways for me to make
that work and I think if Superman it's
do and I'm just frustrated as a fan of
Superman of DC like I just want to get a
little bit more of a grasp of Henry
Cavill super because I think he's got a
good Superman in him I agree and that
was one of my bigger frustrations was
Superman I think suffered the most in
the movie his his storyline and that
scene I was actually looking forward to
him finally getting a chance to say his
piece to finally kind of give his side
of the story and then there's that
bombing the greens peach tea and then
everyone's dead and and again I don't
know how that turned people against
Superman I don't know what Lex is
playing with the bullets and stuff was
because even the news was indecisive on
it like it was it his fault was Bremer
was like what was the point of the scene
it seemed like they kind of sacrifice
developing the character again for
another moment that kind of pushed the
plot forward but I get one better what
do you think I think I super many more
time in this seat that he get that's why
he didn't pass like Wonder Woman and
Batman pass by Superman doesn't pass
because he was reactively homo he was
moping around he didn't have much to do
he was indeed the link the weak link of
the movie and it's his sequel ya know
this is how I feel too can we talk about
that Kevin Costner rock scene like what
was going on expect what's he doing
peyote or something in Alaska like the
last thing I wanted this movie was him
to be a loner again like and then they
went and gave him us the loner scene
with I think I think the most useless
scene in the movie implied
you want to loop back around to the
three hour cut I'm not I think if it
could improve the flow of the movie some
but but I think it's more happier with
its more Superman yes on as long as he's
not a loner in the Iceland breath like
the only thing I do know is that he goes
to Gotham City to investigate Batman so
which I think would have been a useful
thing and I think if you cut the Kevin
Costner scene and maybe put that scene
in because again I think he literally
just started calling Bruce at one point
yes Bruce and it's like whoa whoa so I
get him once how does he know that's
Bruce Wayne yeah it's other than I wish
that I would have put I mean there was
in a monster the Dark Knight when those
savemart the sequence they could have
done in a much to the dynamited series
were you peaked but I uses the extra
vision to look at him and until you peak
that would a break that would have been
cool right yeah hey cuz there was that
moment a trailer in that and uh what's
whatever the beginning of the second
trial I guess where they meet each other
Alexis party yes and I was actually
excited because it showed like Batman
knows who Superman is and super and
clearly knows who's and they're applying
each other
yes in the actual movie I didn't get
that vibe like it just was rushed to it
and there was this like it's clearly
super Clark Kent didn't know who Bruce
Wayne was which was like calm really sad
that he's a reporter you don't know her
Swain is and then I couldn't tell if
Bruce Wayne actually knew who Superman
was like they're ready
there wasn't any detective work who so
hung up on figuring out Lex and the plan
and then I just I was so sad there
wasn't those cool moments of like
exactly the peeking I know I know you
know me or is it just was frustrating
cuz it's for a Batman Superman movie
that's when it's the funnest and
Batman's the detective who figures it
out and can take him out that way
because the flight was great with but it
just it wasn't as effective for me
because we didn't get that pre stuff
well this is a running theme in the
Batman movies of course in Tim Burton's
Batman nobody knew who Bruce Wayne was
and then in Nolan's apparently no one in
Rome knows who Bruce Wayne is either
because he can just walk around and no
one recognizes him we've been the collar
right Ken let's I'm trying to I wanna
get someone who loves the movie to come
yell at us Caitlyn you loved the movie
yes yeah hey Caitlyn welcome right Thank
You Lou all right I want to hear it why
are where are we wrong we're not wrong
but why did you love it so much more
well I gotta say I think the target
audience is people who are willing to
accept like comic book standards enough
but then
not like being neurotic about when
little things are wrong I don't know
because when I was sitting there I was
following along with the prep plot no
problem I was into everybody's acting
I've never hated like the whole Superman
is so dark so when I heard everybody
being like oh this is like sucky or oh
this isn't gonna be so good
I was at the end of that movie being
like there was I don't know I just
didn't see anything wrong with it you
have fun like say solid like you know
8590 movie sure you know that's a
reaction I get Kenny like Whoopie I like
that well I and and and Caitlyn I I have
to push back on you a little bit because
that's what we hear a lot is you're just
being too nitpicky you you're expecting
this it's made for these for this
audience and and again we have to look
at it not just as comic book fans but as
critics and I don't think that
criticizing the structure of a film and
saying that it's it's too scattershot is
is nitpicking personally I particular to
a successful movie but there are a lot
of people in bear town I'm curious what
you think there are people saying like
well it's not made for critics it's made
for comic book fans you know else I
think helped like when we saw it as
critics like they had pressed the fan
screenings came out and were glowing
reviews so it was like best super Behram
ever so the instincts that i got in
going in were literally all the fans
hyping up as the best here that the
movie ever that i think the critics
walked in and they're like whoa there's
some scattershot plot problems here this
is not oh this doesn't hold up yes it's
fun but that's not up and then we
knocked down a peg and so then the fans
are all deflated they go in with these
lowered expectations of right oh man
this can be the worst movie ever and
they're like this is fun and so I think
that definitely almost helped Warner
Bros in a way because fans have to go in
with that sort of intent where we go in
hyped the fans went in a little less
hyped and then we're genuinely more
hyped right I think okay like what I
learned from nightlife and from music
something especially DJ culture you got
to get a feel for the crowd so when I
saw the movie at first with the fan
crowd like there was reactions like her
and people were reacting to the movie so
then I saw it again with critics and you
were there do
was muted sometimes I feel critics have
this not only and it's a very insular
business and they watch movies with
themselves and really watch movies with
crowds so I think critics have to get
started watching movies with the crowd
and making that part of you see how the
crowd is reacting how they feel and I
had two different reactions to different
screenings in two different theaters of
the people they they're having that they
write they clap on queue and when the
woman comes out and does her cross
Gauntlet scene and when she fights
doomsday and the Batman stuff which is
few hours and twenty minutes into it I
know but people are people are engaged
they're engaging they're enjoying
themselves you know so well when you say
it has a centered plot I mean I will say
that there's definitely some moments
where you having to no previous
knowledge fills in the gap but I didn't
think even the stuff that they didn't
explain I didn't think they over
explained I think for if I can explain
what forever because it's not like day I
agree with you Dana completely but it's
a it's a sorceress character motivations
like I think it's hard at I please tell
me it where I'm like they didn't really
justify Superman looks like well but
let's talk about Superman like
Superman's hardly in the movie
Superman's come off of Man of Steel
where he's got this wrestling this
problem and we're basically given a
montage where we finally saved some
people
and then he's really obsessed with Lois
he still hasn't figured out what he
wants to do he's in the ice taka seen
his dead dad he goes off him as a loner
again like there wasn't a much
motivation from him I'm still stuck it
should Superman be in this world they
don't they didn't really answer that
question for me and then right when
Superman I get I love the the build up
of Superman versus Batman right before
it's about to happen
Superman's not then choosing it is Lex
Luthor kidnaps Martha and basically
threatens him and says oh kill him or
I'm gonna kill your mom like that's not
Batman vs Superman like there was with
this big battle we've been waiting for
these two different opinions of things
just sort of it's thrown out the window
because Superman's gotta save his mom
and to me that was that was a
disappointment because I don't think you
needed that I think you have to build up
character motivation for why Superman
doesn't agree with Batman why Batman
doesn't grew Superman I think no I don't
want to bring up Marvel but it's like
you can sort of see the difference
between Iron Man and Captain America
right now like there's just plot points
like in any of these vs. movies like
rock
created rocky like you need to know why
they're fighting and where their
backgrounds are coming from to make that
battle even more effective and I think
had they done that I think we all would
have been just a little bit more excited
or even if you're going to go back to
the source to the Dark Knight Returns
that was very much when they fought and
that was very much an ideological battle
which was Batman the kind of Ben Affleck
version of this yar can give this very
bitter Batman at Superman who was again
kind of fighting for the ideal and I
agree with Andy that was a little bit to
the I was hoping for more of an
ideological battle but but just again
just to fight back I think what people
have to make it accept that we've been
too ethereal for audiences I have to
make it accessible for all true but I
think there's there's a way to do that
but but but when we talk about the plot
being scattered it's not so much that I
couldn't follow it or couldn't
understand it like again and it comes
down to personal preference but just as
a movie goer enough's and as a film fan
there's two ways to tell a story and
basically you know if you tell sorts
like a guy went down to the street and
then he bought something from a guy and
then he tripped and fell and he went
into this crazy world and it's and it
follows and I found the story of
Superman to be like hey guy walked down
the street and then a dog fell from the
sky and the spaceship flew over and then
two cars went by three streets over and
then the guy went into a phone booth and
then two ladies walked in from it's it's
it's not that it was it was hard to
follow it's just that there was no they
were party to in there - there was no
through-line - it is very intense movie
it was very dense and there was nothing
to tie it all together I said before
it's like it felt like a game of Thrones
episode but only one episode and Game of
Thrones works cuz you get a whole season
right and it just felt like we were in
too many plots but kalyan final word go
ahead what's your final thought I guess
I just you know if you want to care to
the Game of Thrones if you watch the
movie knowing that there's going to be
Justice League and having just seen Man
of Steel you're totally fine with it
fair enough fair enough Thank You Kaylin
and I love that you loved it
you're awesome I'm aligned I love that
backdrop of American flag I totally and
Legolas caitlin doesn't seem very happy
with No
we unhappy with us it's not fight here
it's just so we know differences
opinions but can I point something out
though also an inherent flaw in the
rotten tomato system and I and even I've
always said never stress the tomato
meter if you look at the reviews the
negative ones are very mixed they're not
rants against the movie saying this is a
piece of garbage almost all of them are
mixed reviews but because of the system
it's it's a or B and so when people see
29% they think all all the critics hated
this movie and they kind of feel this
vendetta to go up against these people
there and again it's kind of like me
people saying there are good parts and
bad parts but because you have to choose
one way the other what's the audience
score up to now as a 73% this morning
which is pretty visuals out you cinema
score which is kind of that kind of
middle and then 73% audience rating
which is approval you know guys I want
you guys to know you can call in still
while we're taping this a Skype in @sj
I'm sorry screen junkies live if you
want to call in we're gonna be if a
little bit more to take some colors
right now but we want to keep this
discussion going I'd love some people
who really loved it to try and get in
here Skype in screen Ricky's live um
Umberto I mean was your favorite part it
was Batman Batman fight they've marked
the sequence in the third act that whole
seek like from the beginning when he
arrives he kicks a lot a stick we saw in
the trailer he throws people through
drywall he stands we breaks bones he's
brutal we get to see the boot of Bruce
Wayne and Batman
and then the amage to the Dark Knight
scene with cagey beasts I'm a huge KGB's
fan when Jim sterling rode 10 nights of
the Beast okay grant he wasn't the he
didn't come off the way he was in the
college but it was just cool to have him
and then literally ripped out of the
Dark Knight Returns I'll kill her
I'm burning I swear I know boom that's
something I'm a friend of your son's
come on and now that was actually very
effective use of humor yeah and the
movie was was like a friend Rico I'm in
front of your son Joe yeah I guess that
I was named that was a guy I thought
that was a funny moment but it was a
little it just I just wished that it had
been together a little bit for many
years and even you couldn't see Batman
fights and choreographies and Chris
Nolan movies they were they were poorly
shot or you just you couldn't get a
sense of frame or or destination but um
I'm sorry I say there's a topic we've
been saving and we need to get tickets
the fans are dying to talk about Lex
Luthor Lex
let's talk about him it'sit'sit's III we
did that it didn't make the cut in our
spoiler free review I said it's the same
kind of commitment to character that
Heath Ledger brought and that he went a
direction and he went at it hard the
question is was it the right to well
interesting secret I don't know if you
guys didn't heard this the the report of
the photographer in the beginning of
this movie with Lois who gets shot is
Jimmy Olsen which is AK sniper shot
Jimmy Olsen is next is not Jimmy Olsen
the head but there was an interesting
story he was sharing of that was
originally gonna be Jesse Eisenberg so
he brought Jesse Eisenberg to be the
report to be play Jimmy Olsen it was all
going to be a misdirect we're going to
shoot him in the head they're not gonna
see it coming and and Jesse's like okay
yeah I see interesting misdirect
and then as as he was sort of
disagreeing with it Zacks like you know
what I love how uncomfortable jesse has
impregnated me he'd be an amazing Lex
Luthor and so that's where it all was
born from a meeting they had where he
was gonna play Jimmy Olsen which I'm a
that they killed Jimmy Olsen and it
didn't really even own it because we
didn't even meet him in the first movie
right so apparently that's also in this
longer cut as you find out that it is
Jimmy Olsen but again that's kind of a
for a lot of the fans that's a bit of
their prostration is that Zack Snyder's
just like hey Jimmy Olsen I'll shoot him
in the head
I assume that girl Jenny was Jenny Olsen
they were just doing a swap but maybe
that maybe it's a sister but anyway Lex
with her Jessie eyes were did own it he
did she go there but I it just was so
distracting to me like it was exactly
what I was afraid he was gonna be which
was the Mark Zuckerberg version it was
like a little bit was an over
exaggerated Mark Zuckerberg for me and I
just had trouble buying it I just didn't
buy it um it's hard to defend he was
annoying I like us I wasn't too crazy
about Lex I'm expecting Clancy Brown I
guess most audiences were but he was the
most annoying thing about the movie
night I like the movie but he especially
the first shot when he's walking through
the hallway to that over that music in
slow-mo chose like okay that's a tad
much yeah but he was annoying
and it's hard to defend him I'm sorry
it's it's that's maybe the most
polarizing part of the movie is you it's
literally there is no middle ground
there you love it or you hate it I was
not a fan personally most people I don't
think are some people are though that's
but it was a commitment to character
better than Kevin Spacey is the question
that's been coming up on here definitely
yes yeah yeah I wasn't a huge fan of
Kevin Spacey as I still think Cranston
would have killed it yeah I think they
would have been just seriously menacing
I wish instead of Trumbo he took this
well here's the question
we know that he's playing Alexander
Luthor he's basically Lex Luthor jr. do
you think given this response that they
might go back and say okay let's bring
in a Cranston let's bring somebody in to
play Lex Luthor senior and now he is Lex
we know the structure I would love it
yeah things too late it's too late for
that and I want to we have a caller but
I'm gonna talk about Zack Snyder too and
I'm gonna call in because I want to ask
questions should Zack Snyder still be at
the range of this whole thing how well
your live on screen deck is what's your
name where you calling from hey what's
going on guys I am dust and I'm from
Michigan Dustin what do you think of the
movie uh actually I love the movie uh
seen it three times boom with all with
different people and I personally loved
it boom so today what Dustin had just
added just so we can know like you know
did you have any issues with it or do
you think that that we're being Andy and
I are being too harsh on it oh no not at
all I had an issue
I mean biggest issue for me the biggest
glaring thing is definitely the way it
was cut first half the movie it just
seems like it jumps all over the place
so you guys are right but other than
that that's really the only problem I
have and I can't really you guys blame
Snyder you guys blame someone I don't
really think that I think it's mostly
the studio's fault for wanting to cut
the movie down from three hours of two
and a half but Dustin I love you because
we can just agree to disagree you're
respectful come on I love this I love
that you loved it but you really did
yeah um you bring up a good question now
and thank you for calling Dustin who to
blame is there someone to blame is it
Zach Snyder to blame do we think what do
we think good question I think I think
it's too many hands in the kitchen I
think he he didn't make he didn't make
them we he really wanted to make and
it's all that jarring Eddings paint it's
you can see that where the creative
executives put their hands in the
messianism I think I think it's a movie
made by committee quite frankly you've
had your ear to the ground on this for
quite a while we're the reverse
of this movie that you heard about the
stuff that we didn't see that maybe got
sacrificed a three hour and five minutes
that was that tested positively they
screen tested they that's that where you
heard the rumors from there was a
positive screening was that one and then
they cut it down interesting but after
the one in theory they're gonna release
um yes got one which should be
interesting I so I still I still have
I'm not gonna blame Schneider right it's
not who knows cuz I wasn't there but I'd
the only thing I know it's nighter I
sort of who could discredit Center for
is like his treatment of Superman in a
way of just like I just don't feel like
he got enough to do I think you and then
and I but that could be fair the studio
might have said you know what Batman's
what's great about this yeah up up the
Batman and forget the Superman I heard
that and so energies maybe there's an
assault but I just in frustrate because
I don't care that Superman's dark fine
he can be the brooding dark Superman
I'll give in on that but you got at
least give me some more of his
motivations and haven't make the choice
am I gonna be this guy or not like this
hemming and hawing version of a Superman
to me is frustrating he could hem in ha
but he's least got to make a decision
and then we can regret that decision or
be struggling with that decision but
make the damn decision already and to
show me some cool sequences of him
saving the montage was just so oh I see
a thing on the news I'm gonna go save
this person oh they like me and then
he's floating over the people on the
flood just noting that this will give me
one day a moment of mid-fight I gotta go
rescue that guy catch him here go and
say and save it and these were shots
that we saw in the trailer which is
another good point which is in
retrospect that second trailer the
doomsday reveal and which Lerouge people
were saying like well wait and see the
movie you know that did for me have the
structure of the film in it which is
what I was afraid of they redeem they
had a bad trailer before but then they
redeemed themselves at comic-con and you
know Union ladder you anonymously they
drop the boat at the last tombs a
trailer it was again wasn't a rumor they
fired that whole marketing team yes true
because the first comic-con trailer was
fantastic the third trailer they did
after the duty trailer was amazing I was
jumping out of my seat for that trailer
but it does feel like they got a little
knee capped by that decision to reveal
so much in that second trailer they did
well and here's my biggest frustration I
get it yeah it's the problem should they
have shown spider-man should Dave shown
Wonder Woman as the question here of
like I think they could have teased
Wonder Woman in a way without showing
her show
up in that fight and had they done that
I think even critics would have been
wowed and it would just it would have
helped leave a good taste in your mouth
versus I knew was coming and it was cool
but I'd seen the cool shots in the
trailer yeah and it just frustrates me
of like why did you need to show her
saving them and being and all the action
shots it just smelled of were worried we
need to put everything out there so you
know it's here versus let's let's treat
the audience because I think had they
knocked on that same audience when it
came in they would have still pre-sold
they stole it about the tickets and you
had this amazing reveal that I just feel
like the only reveal left that they
didn't spoil it I think is the death
which again I felt was I mean we've
really fully discussed it but I think
even that was sort of wasted well we'll
talk to the death of SAG but I know
there's a lot of people that want to
talk to us we have Jason on the phone
hello Jason hello it's gonna be gone
again hey Jason lot from Ohio what's
good thank you so much what'd you think
of the movie Jason I I'm waiting until I
see the full director's cut before I
give my full opinion on it right now I'm
very mixed okay what did you like about
the movie what I liked is the text
Neider knows how to do action the action
scenes were incredible actually did
really like the montage that Andy was
talking about I just wish they had shown
more like length of at least certain
parts of it just to do like he said give
Cyprus Superman more to do absolutely
and and you can't decide that even
people the biggest Zack Snyder haters in
the world will tell you he can do
visuals oh and that's seventy millimeter
IMAX scene when a cut pops up and
Batman's ready to take him out yeah I
was onboard I just wish they hadn't have
crippled us and then right before that
fight with oh I've your mom captive go
do this for me well and well and while
we're talking about Zack Snyder and we
can talk about this too but Jason going
forward would you like to see Zack
Snyder continue on at the helm of the
Justice League I
I'm interested to see it what honestly
and it's a little unorthodox but I'd
like to see somebody else take over
Justice League and see Zack Snyder go to
just straight-up doing Batman interests
interesting interesting is a lot of
people are saying maybe Ben Affleck to
do Batman
it can't do that right because that's
like is doing it then you know I have
that Ben Affleck at the helm and Zack
Snyder produce or something like the
I just think he works a lot better with
Batman than he does with Superman and we
haven't seen what the rest of the team
yet thank you for coming thank you Jason
umberto you know you know these things
is they can it is it too late
no it's because I spent a considerable
amount money okay so if they replace a
director or they postpone the movie
their stock price is going to tumble
okay and they're their target their
takeover target right now so that stock
price can be tumbling the way it is with
with cancelling the movie like Justice
League will replace and director there
it's a moving train that's already left
the station and they're going to their
do you think they're regretting the
choice I'm not i I'm not sure to be
quite honest I mean the box office is
good the box office is good I mean but
again you know I think everyone knew
this movie would open big the question
will be what are the look is that have a
Man of Steel may still open great the
legs weren't what they'd hoped do you
think it's still gonna deliver the
number that it needs to he'll draw in my
drag to a building and I emphasize the
word drag so so be the second weekend
will be very telling second weekend will
be very telling but it's got a clear
path we do we have another caller hello
will you're live on the show what would
you think in the movie uh I actually
loved it and I've done a lot of thinking
and I'm not fan of menacing it I
actually that is a phenomenon known as
phantom medicine or crystal sculling
also wait exactly what do you love or
what do you what do you disagree with
what we're talking about here well the
funny thing is is I watch your guys's
non-spoiler review first so I went in
with low expectations and I think that
was the big thing is a lot of my friends
that are hating it they just went in
expecting it to be the most amazing film
and I just I guess I knew it wasn't
going to be amazing so I I went I just
kicked back and enjoyed what it was what
what was it that won you over that puts
you on the positive side of it well like
I know you guys uh Batman for one and I
think that uh the opening sequence of
him running in was just some of the best
Batman I've ever seen or Bruce Wayne
should I say yes I would agree that
opening sequence was fantastic yeah I am
totally great I love that opening going
back to what you guys were saying about
um the trailers and giving away so much
you know I actually wrote wrote
something on rotten tomato about this um
I feel like
that kind of falls on us a little bit
because I mean yeah they the marketing
team was really bad at putting out way
too much out there but you know I went
in with friends who had never seen it or
hadn't seen the trailers and they were
so blown away and it's like well then
that's kind of my fault for sitting
there watching every single trailer that
comes out you know
same thing with spider-man and Civil War
I am now gonna be immune to that
surprise because I know it's coming and
that's my fault for sitting there
watching every trailer comes out and
reading every piece of news that comes
out no it's a fair note sadly it's our
job to watch the trailer so we're yeah
but I think it's also just something
that's hard to not want to see a little
tease of the movie and I think you can
still show those teases without showing
the whole kit you know throwing the
kitchen sink at it the force awakens I
think did it perfectly they showed us
enough to get us excited but we went the
III noticed how much reducing movie ever
yeah I wish those works just shows it
can work but I got a number two you work
for a site with you know you deal and
spoilers the it's it's a weird dichotomy
fans don't want to know everything or
they want to know every single thing
they want to know a little they don't
write everything right there I gave him
a minor thing with two that I know like
the Kryptonian spear the one of them
would fight cutting off Doomsday's hand
and the spike coming out a couple other
minor things but like I didn't
personally allow myself to get like when
it's I would when I do when I used to do
spoilers I would do something equivalent
like what a trailer would be like
basically show you something from the
first act and the second act and then
leave it open for the third but they did
show a lot in the schola and the
trailers in the marketing that's for
sure absolutely
well well again we always want people to
have a good time at the movies and I
think this is a mixed movie I certainly
had a good time at parts of it so I say
one more thing absolutely so on the
topic of Zack Snyder I feel like you
know everyone's kind of said the same
thing which is the first part of the
film is really good and I feel like the
reason the second part is really the
studio stepping and saying no we have to
set up this no we have to set up that
and I think that Zack Snyder if you were
given control it would have been better
and I think that that's just not going
to happen with Warner Brothers they're
not willing to do that and
it's it's destroying most their films I
mean I'm looking forward to Suicide
Squad but I'm like oh god what did they
do this I mean it probably could be
amazing but I'm guessing they're gonna
want to set up Batman the next one so
they're gonna you know just shove
something else in that one too
Batman's being fast-tracked that's for
sure yeah oh yeah well because that's
the you net I mean even the biggest
critics of domain money would laugh at
me hello thank you for calling in will
by the way um I want to make sure before
we weren't a time here I want to talk
about the death of Superman because I
know Dan you're specifically had some
fun ideas of work at go Snyder has said
some secrets here he's revealed they
wrestled with that ending shot of should
the dust on the casket move or not right
he didn't know what to date they really
said it was last-minute they weren't
sure which way they were going to go and
then he decided well you know everyone's
gonna just us know and assume he's
coming back so why not at least give a
little bit of a tease that something's
afoot but then I want to kill him I
didn't like that yeah either own it or
don't um or said I wish they would have
saved it and and again that could have
been a great ending to Justice League I
feel like but Dan you said you I know
you had a thought on that well yeah cuz
I came up in the early 90s which is when
Death of Superman happened which was the
biggest thing that had ever happened in
my comic books and and I was saying
build up to it huge build up to it I
mean a year-long build up to it and I
was saying my favorite thing about that
story was that Superman was fighting
doomsday with the the Justice League
that existed at the time which wasn't
the one that that is coming to the
screen but the great thing about it was
that doomsday wrecked everybody and
everyone was incapacitated and he was a
not he could not be stopped and the only
person left was Superman and he
literally they killed each other with
their dying breaths I mean their last
blow
doomsday goes down Superman goes down
he's dead and so I feel like if the
Justice League had been assembled and
you had all of these heroes and then you
have doomsday and doomsday again just
wrecks everybody because it seemed like
Wonder Woman could have defeated him
fairly easily and even Batman was you
know he was at a distance but he was
holding his own I think if you put in
the situation where you have the Justice
League doomsday Rex everybody and then
Superman is literally the only option
left you have the developments and the
relationships he has with all of these
characters it would have meant that much
more and it would have been a great
cliffhanger for the end of Justice
League part 1 how will they go on and
then selfishly I've always wanted to see
a reign of the Superman movie which was
the storyline I think there's even
better than the death of Superman where
you have that's where steel was
introduced the non Shack version and you
had Hank Henshaw you had the Eradicator
you had the Superboy clone and you had
Lois Lane kind of investigating which
one of these the Superman is any of them
Superman that how is he going to come
back and I thought that was a really
compelling storyline that brought the
Kent's into it like that train has
sailed but you know the thing is they
showed Henry Cavill before the movie
came out working on getting ready for
Justice Lee why would he get pumped for
justice I mean it's kind of well they
kill him off yeah but he is coming back
I mean he's buffing his Instagram
account getting ready for Justice League
so yeah they kind of took it out of me
for me at least a little bit so much
yeah it's a waste of a storyline it
seemed to be very much you know the
death of Superman is a monumental thing
and it seemed to be an afterthought in
this film and I really wish that they
could have built that up and made it its
entire great run of a book - well it
really was a really really good book and
that final issue that just like the
panel's go down from 8 to 7 to 6 and
then finally the end is just one panel I
don't know it seemed like an
afterthought in the movie that it could
have made a great moving on its own
absolutely I agree but what can you do
maybe in 50 years they'll they'll redo
everything we'll all be long gone
a Warner Bros really is a deleted scene
I'm trying to watch of something crazy
happening have you seen this yet
literally just went live it is telling
that Warner Brothers is a reaction to I
think it's a reaction to I think it's a
reaction to what's happening is that
Warner Brothers to their credit is an
obviously changing course and we're now
watching this is yeah
but no one of us is immediately changing
course the darks and pushing the
extended cut I think they're hearing
what fans are saying and apparently
something's dropping now I don't know
what's what's exciting is your life
breaking oh yeah we're really gonna fax
it releasing things as we talk is just
they're already pushing the extended cut
I know I'm trying to defend you guys
stop doing it to yourselves making it
harder um Ken do we have anyone on the
phone Cedric on the phone so Jay how are
you how's your sick do we have
out of Mike who is this character if
you're watching online who tell me who
this communion character is do we know
this guy
well while we're out let's talk to
Cedric real quick and then what we can
try to figure that out Cedric welcome hi
actually my name is aurelion I'm on my
brother's account Noah ralien all right
how are you sir
what is he digging annoying thanks I
hated it Dianne's awful um my son's a
giant ad for Justice League and I just
didn't think we need to see we didn't
see that um my biggest problem with the
movie though was not even my biggest
problem but luckily I didn't understand
it all was the sum of the nightmare
sequences Batman had uh-huh especially
the one where he's talking to a guy was
like wrapped electricity or something
and he's screaming out Lois Lane I
didn't see how that was necessary I
didn't see how it said anything up I
mean Batman didn't kidnap Lois Lane I
didn't even know who she was I don't
think I just didn't see how that was how
that mattered well I'm glad you bring
that up cuz we were discussing that
earlier because that's apparently the
flash the for general audiences that's
been the consensus yeah and I was ready
bad boy that's exactly what it is you
think very confusing very confusing
flash in the speedforce suit for those
not in the know does that does that does
that help at all no well I just didn't
see why it was there um that was not a
problem I had when Lois was just
checking out emails we didn't need that
we could have just seen Batman open up
the file seen all that you know cyborg
flash and Wonder Woman and Aquaman and
I'm like oh it's that's great Easter Egg
we get to now speculate what's what's
gonna happen but no we had to see her
opening up the file seeing where they
were that it took away from the movie it
let us in a different direction that we
didn't need just it didn't it didn't
matter I didn't feel it mattered and
again that's the other side of this coin
the people that don't know as much about
the DC Universe do you think that could
have worked as a and again I they
probably want to do it because they
don't want to be compared to Marvel as a
post-credits scene the reveal on the
Justice League yes I definitely believe
it could have been a bust it could have
been like duh you know what if you take
that Wonder Woman scene mm-hmm and put
that after the fight yet she's back home
now she
chillin and then she puts up the
computer I would have definitely been a
had that structural year that would have
been an awesome post credit sequence
well you know like I said it takes it's
again it just shows how divisive that
movie is really thank you so much for
calling for callin an acute I keep
teasing just if I'm gonna play as we're
talking I don't know what this character
source of this is Warner Brothers just
released can you cut to this
hello JT but you come on are you live in
there there we go thank you who is this
character they're about to show us so
this is a deleted scene that they just
released this okay here we go
oh that's
the brother
it can't be dark so he doesn't look
happy you do friends oh this is
obviously when he's in the tank
communion I don't know what the hell
that means that was was yesterday
that appeared to be an alien from
Independence Day I'm not quite sure but
again I think that excuse people even
FRA infused by that knowledge I'm trying
to defend y'all when you're doing this
to me but again who is that care out so
it's another character it's a reality
video game yeah they're already pushing
the extended versions of these movies so
and it's very interesting is that's not
Darkseid come on no that's not my god
it's not a common acceleration of
Darkseid at least our science is very
Donald honest like exactly uh no one
seems to know in the comments hello tell
me nobody knows all right but ya know
tweet us on the phones young yeah SJ BBS
phone be I would call him Diablo for now
well we're close we got open wolf
Steppenwolf all right well anyway you're
look up Steppenwolf let's try to deny
one or two more calls here I can do we
have anybody on the line we will in just
a moment um breaking news guys news
exactly we do alright hello you're on
the air
hey guys that's going good how are you
doing I like that shirt Thanks so what's
your name first of all I'm Tom I'm
calling from Delaware today Tom from
Delaware thank you so much for calling
what'd you think of the movie Tom
overall I liked it
ok cool hi so I I agree with a lot of
the issues that you guys had especially
in your reviews I enjoyed the movie but
there are a lot of problems I wouldn't
call it a good movie by any stretch of
the imagination uh but it was fine oh
yeah it was fun I enjoyed the fight the
fight was great I really wish it ended
kind of like how it didn't the Dark
Knight Returns rather than Martha Marco
Saint Martha again and I think that's
the
even at the consensus of the lewodan
like it was the fights they look great
they're fun they're entertaining fights
but it's it's really you know is that
enough or does it feel like it's in
service to the story enough that's I
think where the real dividing line is
tough ed look like you like you said Dan
with your review with the five different
so Paul with the five different movies
going on uh-huh I think if you yank out
the Wonder Woman in costume fighting
with doomsday it makes it substantially
better movie maybe if that was a what
mano-a-mano matchup between Superman and
doomsday potentially so I don't you know
but that would be a Superman movie and
everyone loves Wonder one that's the
thing that the Wonder one looked
fantastic and and it she looked great
and she fighting style was amazing she
was into a snow demon and that matches
my levels and she's like into the fight
yeah gal gadot which I'm learning it's
not Godot its gadot the people who
corrected me in the comments okay gadot
I think was great and I look forward to
the Wonder Woman standalone movie but
yeah I think the real dividing line is
are you story based or was it enough to
see everybody there which is great and I
can't deny that
absolutely Andy any update on sorry
first of all Tom thank you for calling
yeah I mean there's a it's either yoga
con it's a new God is what played a
patriarch of apocalyptic ellipse not
just spelled differently different
apocalypse but it's either yoga con or
Steppenwolf either/or but the New Gods
are all related to dark side it's more
dark side teasing
he's Dart if it's if it's seven all this
dark sides uncle if it's yoga con he's
one of the rulers of the New Gods I
don't I'm not not as familiar new God so
I'm trying to wiki as hard as I could if
I recall apocalypse is dark sides like
base but it does look like those cubes
he's holding are the same ones that
cyborgs using with STAR Labs with
helping I did I mail decipher that at
least but there we go stuff is still
drama good exact we're set up and it
they did for more secrets that in the
Batman nightmare sequence you can see
the omegle a local symbol in the desert
which again
Darkseid's clearly coming dark sides
clearly in this universe they're not
hiding it with those sort of do these
now especially with this to that's
clearly the bigger bad as where the
Thanos of you will of DC and also the
for STAR Labs which is a big player in
DC universe maybe might even have a role
in bringing Superman back I know they
attempted to in the comic book STAR Labs
was was very heavily trying to bring the
Man of Steel back sojourn there Silas
stone that was the one cameo didn't work
for me because it had a little bit of a
horror element to it it was just great
yeah very body hard way to introduce
cyborg yes miss torching is something
like that Wow it'll be just having them
over a sheet would have been more yeah
it's those showing us his insides in his
lungs so let's take one more call and
then we'll wrap it up here Ken who do we
have on the line we have Lauren on the
line Lauren hello thanks for calling in
what'd you think of the movie please
like it I enjoyed it uh nice all right
what do you think are what I mean why
what was your favorite part or what do
you disagree with what we're talking
about here um my favorite part
no one's gonna agree with me but I
enjoyed Lex Luthor a lot well there you
go yeah what did you like tell metell us
why uh you know he went for it it was
unique it was something you know I think
it was a change of pace he would come in
and it was um it just changed the movie
up it gave it a bit of a lighter
different tone and that you can't
disagree with that it was completely a
different tone from anything else in the
movie absolutely I never seen it like we
said it's love it or hate it some people
are gonna this is their Lex Luthor and
they love it and I can't you know
that's personal profit at least he
shaved his head at the end he did we got
a bulb Lex Luthor ish at the end I still
want to wish that he was branded by the
bad minister to the wall I would've been
cool if Lex was they had a Batman brand
on it Oh knows who he is that's true I
mean he's the one who sent the letters
everybody for you for the longest I was
a joke or something letters no it was
the letters I didn't quite get it
selects was saying the letters oh you
guys know nod and get that it was a
little coming right okay okay look let
me be matrix right you can read the top
uh look a little letter here live it
here you let your family die you
remember when he was acting out for uh
for Lois Lane yeah he's the one who's
he's the one who sent the letters to
provoke Batman to fight Superman but did
he thinks did he think Superman was
sending him letters and they know he'd
send the pictures to see your friend you
figured out in the unready
but he he sent the pictures too he send
the pictures to Clark Kent right as he
knew he was Clark Kent how I don't know
right you news Clark Kent some knew
everything he had every justice Justice
League member yes jury executioner and
then he would and then he would do the
same thing to Bruce Wayne today he would
in segi was instigating you see here's
my right I love that but it wasn't clear
and then I had you guys you know hated
it he was I hated that
Lex couldn't have just made it been
clever enough to get them to fight on
their own without having to kidnap
Martha yeah to me that to me was a big
letdown was Bruce supposed to think that
Superman was sending him letters in the
middle he didn't know who he thought
there was no sway veteran from I felt
that the veteran was sending him those
letters right right to provoke him who
blows up the Congress I'm not thinking
you yes senator are you they originally
thought with Jimmy Olsen but that's kind
of an example of things that just happen
in the movie that just don't seem to
like I get that Lex if Lex was sending
the letters but I'm he's I don't know
what but but to what purpose
to get to tend to fight Superman I don't
know how that would provoke him to fight
Superman well look it's like me crazy
for Superman to fight a minute listen
people like a movie that's all that
matters I think again a final thoughts
as we go here is I I'm glad people liked
the movie I'm not trying to change minds
I just wish Warner Brothers and the
people behind this would have taken a
little bit more time to develop these
heroes because I think had they done
that they would have made even more
money and they would have made even more
people happy I'm happy the comics fans
are happy I just think these two heroes
actually really are my two favorite
superheroes and I just didn't feel like
it was fully earned it was cool I just
wish it had been a little bit better I
don't disagree with you I feel it I wish
the movie was in his devices but it was
fun for what it is I'll eat I'm happy at
least it exists at the DC as the softest
at least a start it's a weak first
quarter let's see if they come back for
the second quarter and strong and close
out the half before the second half of
their slate but it was fun I'm gonna go
see it again with a crowd one more time
next weekend but it's it there's no
denying that it's divisive and it's a
very flawed moving but it works it's fun
that's what it's supposed to be and yeah
exactly it's not a is divisive as it is
not high art it's not high art but I
think that more people actually came out
of it positively than maybe Man of Steel
I think that that even people that
didn't like it are excited by parts of
it and you know I'm a comic book fan I'm
gonna be excited when Wonder Woman comes
out and I'm gonna be excited when
Justice League part one comes out
because the story has not been written
on any movie until it has unspooled in
the theaters
hashtag support DC films hashtag support
has tech support all films yes except
for transformers so I want to thank
everybody that called in today everybody
that wants to talk about Batman V
Superman this discussion will continue
it will continue and if you want to talk
to us live we have a lot of shows live
on store Nucky's plus we're happy to
give us on youtube because we knew this
was one everyone wanted here but join us
there of Riskin Achatz plus thank you so
much for watching everybody
exactly andi signor where could they
find you any signal our Twitter
Instagram and now on Facebook look up my
public profile please and don't forget
we are making movie fights for uh if
you're watching Plus member it'll be
live Tuesday tomorrow night into
Thursday TV fights movie fights are
swapping yep I mean Harley from Epic
Meal times come in mark and Draco and I
believe John Campea is finally going to
step in the ring yes it's might be a we
have some more surprises so stay tuned
it's gonna be all Batman Superman fights
so get ready and if you watch on YouTube
you will be able to see that on Saturday
as always Umberto Gonzales where can
they find you you can find me at heroic
Hollywood calm and online i'm @hardwick
hollywood common on social media and we
just launched a youtube show called
heroic insider available at pop boom
youtube.com populum TV so make sure to
subscribe and I'll let you guys know
what's happening next on Wednesday there
you go that's if you want inside
information this is the man to go to and
you can find me on twitter at merle dan
and right here on screen junkies thank
you to everyone who called in thank you
to everyone wouldn't saw this movie and
shared their opinion with us we love to
talk movies and that's what movies is
all about going to find something you
love and talking about it with other
people that love it thanks for watching
and we'll see you soon bye
take care guys ghost you hey screen
junkies now that we've weighed in on
Batman V Superman you can weigh in on
our own epic contest the honest trailer
for Batman 89 versus the honest trailer
for Superman 78 so click your favorite
now even on your phone and make your
choice your views will decide the winner
and determine a future honest trailer
you